Were these differences in belief systems?
Just arbitrary.
And that's actually a postmodern question.
I didn't know that at the time.
No,
because you might say the postmodernists
do say there's a very large number of
ways of interpreting the world and it
isn't obvious how you determine which of
those ways are correct and so perhaps
you can't determine that any of them are
correct.
And then as a consequence of your
inability to determine if any of them are
correct,
then you have to turn to something
like power dispute to establish which
interpretation is going
to take precedence.
I would say in a nutshell,
that's a postmodern is theory.
Now that's tainted to some degree
with Marxist preconceptions,
but we won't get into that.
But that's basically the idea and
it's an idea with a certain amount of
justification.
There is a very large number of ways
of interpreting the world and it isn't
obvious which way or ways are
right or why they're right.
So it's a complicated problem.
And so I was curious,
he's like,
was this merely a difference of opinion?
The West had a certain set of axioms that
it was acting out in the world and the
Soviet bloc and the rest of the communist
countries had another set of axioms
and they were both arbitrary and it was
a matter of power or was there something
deeper at stake?
So that was question number two.
Question number three was
was there an alternative to brutal combat?
Was there an alternative way of solving
the dispute too brutal group combat,
something like that.
And so cause I always believed that if
you understood the problem that you could
solve it.
In fact that if,
if when you analyze the problem,
a solution didn't emerge
from the analysis,
then you actually didn't
understand the problem.
And so I thought if I
delved into the problem deeply enough,
then maybe I could figure out
what might constitute a solution.
And assuming there was such
a thing because I couldn't,
I knew after writing a fair
bit of it that we were,
that there was a real problem because
you can get belief systems that are
locked in combat and then obviously the
terrible consequence
of that is the combat.
But then I also knew,
and this was probably more from
reading nature than anything else,
that if your belief system collapses,
you might say,
well,
I don't want to fight with you about
whose belief system is correct.
I'll just let my mind go.
But the problem is if you
let your belief system go,
then you're swamped by
nihilism and hopelessness and,
and that's not helpful.
First of all,
it's very,
it's not helpful psychologically because
it produces emotional pain and anxiety
and maybe at unbearable levels
you can't have a pointless life.
It's,
it's,
it's a suffering,
a pointless life is pointless suffering
and people can't sustain that without
becoming demoralized.
That's only where they start demoralized,
bitter,
cruel,
resentful,
angry,
hostile,
murderous,
genocidal.
Like all those things
follow one from another if,
if things are sufficiently hopeless.
So you can't just let
your belief system go,
but if you're locked into it and there's
another one that you're competing with,
then the,
the consequences war.
It's like,
so what is it nihilism on the one hand
and war on the other that didn't seem
like,
especially given outcome of
like say it the Third World War,
that neither of those seemed
like acceptable alternatives,
but I couldn't see any other,
I couldn't see that there was anything
else other than those two alternatives.
And so that's what I tried
to lay out in this book.
Maps of meaning most of the thoughts
that I expressed in 12 rules for life,
not all of them,
and in the lectures that I've done
that have become popular on Youtube,
were all developed during the 15 year
period that I worked on that book and I
worked on it.
I would say obsessively really.
I wrote about three hours a day and I
thought about it for pretty much 12 other
hours.
And so I was thinking constantly.
It was,
it's not an obvious why,
but,
well,
I told you why for some reason all that
manifested itself to me as a cardinal
problem,
but I concluded and tried to
lay out the rationale for this,
that
the,
the fight between these
two belief systems,
but let's,
let's look at the belief systems.
It's not communism versus the West.
It's not communism versus the free market.
It's,
it's different than that.
It's collectivism in it's far right form,
let's say the far right form of the Nazis
and the far left form of the radical
leftist,
the communists that's
collectivism versus individualism.
That's the fundamental conflict.
And there are variants of
the collectivist viewpoint,
but it doesn't matter.
They can be grouped under
the rubric of Collectivism.
There's important differences,
but we don't have to get into that.
But the western take wasn't collectivist.
It was individualist and the central
idea of the West was that although people
are obviously obviously aggregate
into groups and many different groups,
cause all of you are members of
very of many different groups,
ethnicities,
genders,
sexes,
races,
family groups,
community groups.
You can be grouped a very large number
of ways and you tend towards the adoption
of something approximating a
group identity because you know,
you take care of your family and you're
a member of your community and you have
a certain amount of justifiable
patriotism in relationship to your state.
The group identity is
definitely part of who you are.
The question is what the fundamental
defining characteristic of who you are and
the collectivists is that you
are the Avatar of a collective.
And that's fundamentally who you are.
But the western perspective is not that.
The Western perspective is that despite
the fact that people have an individual
level and a collective level,
the individual level is to
be regarded as paramount.
You're to be treated above all
else above all as an individual.
Now,
and I looked into that very deeply
and I thought that isn't arbitrary.
It's actually correct.
That's the right way of
looking at the world.
And then you might say,
well,
what do you mean the right way?
And of course that's the right
question because that is the question.
If something's the right
way of looking at something,
well why is it the right
way of looking at it?
But I want to put a little spin on that
too because usually when we talk about
individualism in the West,
at least in the modern world,
maybe let's say for the last 50
years or something like that,
maybe it's after World War II,
I don't know exactly the parameters.
It doesn't matter.
Certainly since the 1960s when we think
about the tradition of individuality in
the west,
we think about the tradition of individual
rights and there's a problem with
that because
the fundamental individual tradition of
the West is not individual rights and
rights have a problem.
Rights are sort of like you're
privileged compared to other people.
I have these rights and don't tread on
them that that wall's me off and makes me
privileged in some sense.
It means that I have
the right to do things.
I have the right to
pursue my own interests.
I have the right to pursue happiness,
for example,
that's explicitly laid out
in the American system.
The rights or what is special about me?
And so when you look at individuality
or individualism from that perspective,
you can think about it as a selfish idea.
And it's often criticized by collectivists
precisely for that selfishness.
But the fundamental idea of the
individual in the West isn't predicated on
rights.
Even though that's important,
it's predicated on responsibility,
right?
So your role as an individual in the
West isn't to be the bearer of rights of
intrinsic rights.
Even though those are important,
your responsibility as an individual in
the west is to bear the responsibility
of an individual.
And it's in bearing that
responsibility that you set yourself,
right,
and your family,
right?
And You keep the state on track.
It's not from expressing your rights,
it's from shouldering your responsibility.
And I would say that the reason that you
have rights in the West is so that you
can shoulder your responsibility.
It's not the other way around.
It's so that you can do what's best
on your behalf and in that manner,
what's best on your family's behalf and
in that manner contribute to the degree
that you can to the community.
And that if you do all
those things simultaneously,
which means to accept the
responsibility for that,
then things move ahead as
well as they can move ahead,
which doesn't necessarily mean well
because life is very difficult and there's
no sure way through it.
There's only less bad approaches.
That might be a way of thinking about it,
and the least bad approach you can manage
is to shoulder your responsibility as
an individual.